Salut aujourd'hui, comme promis, je réponds à vos questions
voici donc la 1ère FAQ du MentalVlog
je suis super étonné, je ne pensais pas avoir autant de questions en fait
à vrai dire je pensais en avoir peut être une 20aine ou un truc comme ça
il y a eu plus d'une centaine de questions qui ont été posé entre celles sur YouTube, celle sur Twitter, sur Facebook, sur snapchat
vous m'avez snapper des questions. C'est drôle
du coup c'est des questions très courte
bref il y en a eu de partout
alors j'ai essayé d'en réunir... celle qui représentait un petit peu un ensemble
J'ai élu des questions délégué de classe
Je retrousse les manches, C'est parti
Mon setup vidéo, ben... il est pas très compliqué, j'ai une Canon Legria mini X celle qu'on a tous je crois
C'est celle qu'à Pierre Croce, celle qu'à Vérino, celle qu'à Kyan Khojandi
je l'ai depuis quelques années aussi, elle est très pratique pour l'emmener partout
j'ai aussi une GoPro c'est celle que je me met soit sur moi, soit sur la personne que je mentalise pour que vous ayez le point de vue
Et comment je m'y prends pour réaliser mes vlogs,
et bien vaste question,
bonne part d'improvisation mais sinon je gratte des idées, en fait, j'ai des petits carnets comme ceci
où je marque mes idées directrices
et je vais piocher dedans, d'un point de vue général j'ai toujours ma caméra sur moi
et si je croise un pote, et beh je lui fais un MentalVlog parce que j'ai pas le temps. Une par jour j'ai pas le temps d'attendre
"une journée type pour toi c'est quoi?" C'est galère. Je me lève beaucoup trop tôt, vous allez vous moquer de moi c'est sûr
mais c'est tellement sûr, je me lève maintenant à 8h 8h30 du matin
mais avant je ne me levais jamais à cette heure-ci
je me levais un peu plus tard, tu vois
et pas tous les jours! surtout pas
j'ai pas trouvé mon rythme de croisière, c'est à dire que même le dimanche je me lève
euh... il faut... il faut que je m'organise
j'ai déjà dis ça dans une vidéo d'ailleurs
Faut que je m'organise
C'est clair.
La journée type pour moi c'est surtout de faire en sorte que le Vlog ne me prenne pas toute la journée, tu vois
mais on va dire qu'entre le fait d'écrire une idée, le fait de gratter un peu de texte, de tourner, de monter
d'habiller le montage, de mettre sur YouTube, de la partager
l'ensemble ça doit me prendre... entre 2 et 3h
quand ça me prends 2h c'est bien
2ième question
Faut pas que je sois aussi long à chaque question, ça va faire une vidéo de 3h
Bon bah ça j'ai répondu à ça. Non je ne trouve pas de temps pour souffler
Q'est ce qui m'a encouragé à faire ce défi, bin le fait que ce soit un défi en fait
en tout cas pour moi. Tu sais si tu regardes la 1ère vidéo ça c'est passé comme je t'ai dis en faite
Tu vois il y avais Vérino qui me motivais à faire des vidéos
y'a Jeanne qui m'as fait découvrir le format Vlog
une fois que j'ai eu cette idée en tête, elle m'a plus quitté en fait. Je ne pensais qu'à ça
donc.. je sais pas si ça m'a encouragé mais en tout cas à un moment donné, il a fallu que je le fasse.
Je vais noter les questions au fur et à mesure
parce que sinon quand je vais monter je vais galérer
et comme il faut que je publie la vidéo dans 1h30
Jeanne... c'est une des 1ère vidéo d'ailleurs que j'ai fais
je l'ai mentalisé en vidéo et elle a fait une vidéo sur moi en fait
où elle se sent persécutée. Elle fait un peu peur d'ailleurs dans cette vidéo. Je vous mettrai le lien quelque part soit dans les descriptifs
soit par ici autour de moi
elle a trouvé apparemment, selon elle, une arme pour pas que je puisse vous mentaliser
Est ce que ça marche?!
Alors déjà NON j'ai pas fait voeu de chasteté de la fiesta
je vais te dire même quelques choses j'ai pas fait vœu de chasteté de vacances
alors je sais pas comment je vais faire
mais
je vais le faire. En faite, ça c'est déjà passé une fois... c'était le lendemain de l'Européen avec Lamine Lezghad
le vendredi soir j'étais avec Lamine, on s'est couché tard, on a un peu picolé et tout
quand je suis rentré j'ai pas eu le courage de monter la vidéo et .... le lendemain on était samedi
et la vidéo elle doit être en ligne à 11h
donc je me suis levé en fait pour l'instant à part me lever je ne vois pas d'autres solutions
Ah oui donc Marine on pars de loin. Marine vlog c'est une contraction entre blog et vidéos
C'est pas V L O G en fait ça ça veut rien de dire de spécial. Ou alors ça veut dire Vidéo Longue où Olicard Gère
Je prends très mal cette question, ça veut dire que tu trouves que c'est pas original ce que je fais. Je te réponds pas.
Oula alors attends je vais te la lire pour de vrai Jeremy
"Slet j'adore ta chaine ton spectal-ce
Je t'ai vu à Avignon on avais parlé vite fa-aise
hâte de te revoir et ma question comment as tu Ute envie de devenir mentaliste?"
En fait j'ai pas vraiment Ute envie de devenir mentaliste
j'ai découvert le mentalisme avec les choses auxquelles je m'intéressais au départ, à savoir la magie, les choses sur la mémoire, les choses sur la psychologie
et un jour j'ai trouvé qu'il y avais un nom qui englobais tout ça et qui s'appelais le mentalisme
voilà comment j'ai Ute envie
est ce que ma réponse te vate?
Le problème de Jeanne c'est que des fois elle fait peur
je crois que j'ai un petit peu traumatiser Jeanne
Oui j'ai d'autres animaux j'ai un chat qui s'appelle Tamalo
il est déjà dans une des vidéos Fabien Olicard te mentalise en vidéo
c'est les vidéos que je faisais avant de lancer le Vlog, il y en avais une par mois.
donc tu peux le voir. Je crois que c'est dans la vidéo 3, 4, 5 ou 6
*rire*
une fourchette un petit peu large
et tu peux aussi voir Tamalo dans le récap n°4
que j'ai mis ce dimanche là sur Facebook et sur YouTube
euh... il est ici
C'est d'ailleurs sa place préférée, c'est à dire quand je travaille moi sur mon bureau. Il se met là car il y a le radiateur
et donc il "spoque" ici
et il dors là et il me fous des poils partout
et ce qui est magnifique c'est qu'il aime bien les petits endroits chaud donc il aime bien mon mac parce que mon mac il est chaud et il se pose dessus
il envoie des mails, il met des commentaires, ça ne veut rien dire. Si encore c'était efficace et productif
Du vert
Alors si tu parles de l'homme qui parlait à l'oreille des cheveux. Bon
et que tu vois pas où est le jeu de mot
c'est que le cinéma ne t'intéresse pas tellement tellement
par contre j'aurai du mettre murmurait
au lieu de parlait mais comme murmurait c'était beaucoup trop gros et ça rentrait pas ça m'a soûlé et donc j'ai mis "l'homme qui parlait à l'oreille des cheveux"
et si tu parles du titre pourquoi le X-files des coupes de cheveux
je t'avoue que j'en sais rien du tout en fait
depuis tout à l'heure je regarde ça et je me dis "ben oui elle a raison pourquoi j'ai appelé ça le X-files des coupes de cheveux"
il doit y avoir un truc derrière, je devais avoir une idée au départ. Tu sais j'ai dû avoir un début d'idée
je suis pas allé au bout et je sais plus
je sais plus du tout pourquoi
le X-files des... m'enfin Fabien
je sais pas
comme il faut que je mette des titres et des descriptifs aussi tout les jours
ça c'est... c'est une tuerie en faite. A chaque fois tu dis "Ah qu'est ce que je vais mettre". J'ai du avoir une idée. Je ne sais pas
Je suis désolé Salomé
Bien sûr, il faut que je sache un peu ton numéro de compte et une étude graphologique aussi serait nécessaire
donc si tu peux m'envoyer un chèque, tu le signes ça me permettra après d'analyser ta signature
d'analyser le numéro de compte, de voir quelle banque c'est, et t'inquiète pas
tu vas pas être déçu
Damien Larralde, on était au lycée ensemble avec Damien
écoute Damien j'ai trop de bons souvenirs à la Rochelle. Je peux pas te dire... y'a l'époque... y'a une époque musicale Oui
je jouais de la musique
y'a y'a trop de choses à la Rochelle
trop. tout
En fait, je fais pas forcément qu'avec les humoristes
ça, ça vient juste du fait que c'est le milieu dans lequel je travaille
euh... donc forcément ceux que je croise c'est mes collègues de boulot. Ce sont les humoristes
C'est pour ça que vous en voyez beaucoup
mais... mais si j'étais
j'étais comptable vous croiseriez des comptables dans mes vidéos
ça serait pareil
Dans la rue j'aimerai bien en fait, c'est juste que c'est compliqué de mettre en place
et comme je veux essayer de ne pas utiliser plus de 2/3h de ma journée pour le MentalVlog
j'aimerais qu'il y ait des gens plus normaux que les humoristes
parce que non un humoriste c'est pas quelqu'un de tout à fait normal dans sa tête. Non
*rire* J'ai donc reçu une carte postale de Marine Fougasse
Alors la carte de vœux, c'est parce que j'avais envoyé les cartes de vœux que j'avais en trop à tout ceux qui m'avais envoyé un message les 30 premiers en tout cas
cool que vous ayez reçu,c'est chouette. Et alors, pour la croix déplacée de la main
je trouve ça beau d'oser poser cette question en faite
et je trouve ça beau d'avoir la naïveté de penser qu'on aura une réponse
C'est flippant un peu, Jeanne au bout d'un moment
si jamais il m'arrive quelque chose
que durant quelques jours je ne poste plus de vidéos , que vous n'avez plus de nouvelle de moi. Envoyez les flics chez Jeanne
Je vous mets son adresse dans les commentaires
Bon courage Jeanne
Du travail, j'ai pas de don. Je ne suis pas médium, je suis pas voyant, je suis pas télépathe. J'utilise des techniques en fait
pour vous bluffer, pour vous faire marrer mais c'est du travail
à la limite si j'ai un truc un peu particulier, c'est que j'ai une bonne mémoire de base
mais voilà j'ai pas de capacité particulière au départ
C'est gênant Olivier
Pour les 100 000 je m'y engage
bon alors ça, ça voudrait dire qu'on aurait atteint les 100 000 avant la fin de l'année
donc je prends pas trop de risques
Pour les 100 000 je fais un numéro tout nu
il n'y a pas de problème c'est un engagement, Olivier Nicoleau
"il doit bien y avoir des fois où ça marche pas. Comment fais tu dans ce cas là". C'est vrai Lizzy tout à fait, il y a des fois où ça marche pas et comme vous avez pu voir sur la vidéo avec Joachim
mon diffuseur et comme vous allez pouvoir le voir sur une vidéo que j'ai pas encore mise en ligne, celle de demain d'ailleurs
des fois je suis un petit peu à côté voilà. Et quand ça marche pas et bien je fais quoi... J'assume et je vous met la vidéo. Parce que voilà c'est comme ça
ça peux arriver
"Et utilises tu des trucs de mentalistes dans la vie de tous les jours, négocier un contrat, savoir quand quelqu'un ment"
Ben non j'ai de la déontologie
utiliser ça à des fins personnels. Attends ça serait pas bien
Non
Voilà c'était la 1ère FAQ, c'était les... les ...j'ai sélectionné 20 questions qui représentaient bien tout ce que vous m'avez posé dessus
J'espère que les réponses vous ont plu. Elles sont pas écrites à l'avance elles ont été spontanées
Si cette vidéo vous a plu, je vous propose de mettre un petit pouce en l'air, parce que ça c'est important
ENCORE plus important, abonnez vous à la chaîne YouTube
et si tu es dans le sud n'oublie pas toute cette semaine je joue de Mercredi à dimanche à Aix en Provence au café théâtre La Fontaine d'Argent. Viens me voir là bas
On peux se rencontrer, on peux se faire une vidéo ça serait vraiment cool. J'espère te voir là bas
quoi qu'il arrive on se retrouve demain pour le prochain MentalVlog à 17h sur la chaîne YouTube.
Ciao!